[Music]
How are you greetings by Cristian Cásseres with
his brief informative for News Now in
Spanish We begin with the tributes
around the valley after 20 years of the
attacks on the Twin Towers on Saturday
morning the
Las Vegas Fire and Rescue Department  will
pay homage to those who died on
9/11 starting at 6:45 in the morning,
the former New York firefighter, Frank
Pizarro, will be in charge of singing the
national anthem. He was one of those who responded
to the attack and helped save several
people.  will take place at the
station located near bolivia and
charleston some local business owners
are concerned about the new
kobe-related requirements
established by the federal government the
new rules indicate that businesses
with more than 100 workers must
prove that their workforce is
vaccinated or must prove a
negative covina test
weekly The Las Vegas Greens will open their
regular season Monday within  or
ali and jane stadium against the
baltimore ravens fans
attending must be vaccinated so they
can go without masks remember
to use the clear app to
turn in your proof of
cob vaccination otherwise you may
face delays getting  enter the
stadium and we will see a drop in
temperatures we will have chances of
rain again in the valley although
we will continue with temperatures in
triple digits and you will feel some
humidity in the next few days I am
cristian cásseres with your
informative award from news now in Spanish good
day
[Music]